the Joe Rogan experience I feel if I was
gonna go out and go kill something cute
and fuzzy if I [ __ ] had a uh you know
total hypocrite cause I am a mediator
anyways if I used a bow and arrow I
would feel like an accomplishment i
watch Ted Nugent kill a bear which I
could never do you know when there's all
these [ __ ] places to just get a
chicken sandwich do I really need to
make a [ __ ] you know a bear double
cheeseburger do you want to try some
bear sausage in the freezer back there
would you try it if I gave it to you
no really no cuz I went to the zoo one
time and I saw this bear and it was
funny because it was sitting half in the
water and half out and had its arms
that's arms its front legs [ __ ] like
it looked like it was sitting in a
Jacuzzi like a lounge and we pulled up
on the bus to look at it and it was just
the way it looked I kind of locked I met
eyes with the thing and I knew what was
thinking put like the video you know
they're killing the deer in the backyard
while it's eating it alive and the deer
screaming cuz you need to know what a
bear really is when you see bears in
real life you go oh that's what that
thing it's a [ __ ] killing bear would
just punch it in the head to stop
hearing to do this see that look at that
thing no you're gonna buy the neck no
it's taking chunks out of it bro Beleza
the reason why that thing's screaming
this is because it's biting its back
okay that's enough
that's what sounds like me trying to
touch my toes every morning you know
what's hilarious you know my daughter
does one which she likes to stretch with
me she thinks it's funny and she makes
those noises cuz I think she's supposed
to so she goes seek when she goes so
gives I want stretchy dad that and then
she goes uh-oh
like I have like a foam roller and I'll
she'll come walk in a room and she look
at me she'll smile and just funny she
sits on it because she doesn't know how
to use it she sits down she just goes oh
that's hilarious
my wife laughs at me guy that's he's
imitating how old you are
[Laughter]
[Applause]